make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay uh mariah is upstairs doing I don't
know what she's doing but you guys may
hear her walking around because she
stomps she stomps when she walks she's
just like boom boom boom was like you're
beyond over the scene from Jurassic Park
when like the t-rex was coming and like
the water was shaking like sometimes
that's what it's like she just stomps
throughout like sometimes like pictures
would be crooked I'm just like good lord
woman how do you stop around this but I
was one oh I wouldn't go hey I was
watching I was reading online and there
are these rumors circulating around
about the High Evolutionary in in
guardians of the galaxy 3 right and and
this is this is intriguing to me now I
know that Kevin Feige did a asked me
anything on reddit right and and you
know I don't know what all was said
because I haven't read the whole thing
really having read any of it actually
but off the top my head when I think
about the High Evolutionary and
guardians of the galaxy 3 my first
thought goes to his involvement with
Adam warlock but at the same time I kind
of feel like it'd be a little too much
right like to throw the High
Evolutionary in there having Adam
warlock show up and be the main villain
of the film because that's really what
he was right so a little bit of history
here for those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with the whole High
Evolutionary Adam warlock you know that
that that whole situation so when Adam
warlock first showed up in the MCU I'm
sorry Anna in Marvel Comics he was just
known as him right and in the Fantastic
Four comics there was this group called
The Enclave and they wanted to use like
you know science and technology as it
means to like conquer the world
essentially and Adam warlock was their
first creation in terms of creating like
a perfect human the issue that you ran
into here that they ran into who is that
without a Morlock being kind of just
stated in a cocoon when he emerged it
was too bright and too much for them to
be able to see and so what they did is
they kidnapped Alicia masters who was
the blind girlfriend of Ben Grimm from
the Fantastic Four from the thing
basically and then brought her to the
enclave headquarters and then had her
like sculpt the face of Adam warlock
based on you know what it wasn't she
felt so they could actually see what he
was supposed to look like that led of
course the Fantastic Four showing up and
the Fantastic Four fought Adam warlock
and then he took off into space now that
leads into like his involvement with
Thor right which kind of ties
the galaxy and when that happened it was
the idea that Adam warlock had tried to
take SIF to be his wife and that led to
a fight between himself and Thor and
then of course he took off after that
but from there that's when it starts to
give in to the the whole High
Evolutionary thing and soso when you
when you look at Adam warlock and you
look at like the writers of his
characters his stories over the years
he's really had like two huge writers
who have done more to like change his
character and really sort of elevate him
and evolve him than almost any other
writer the first that are not really the
first but the but one that most people
know about is jim Starlin right with a
guy who would infinity war Infinity
Gauntlet all that kind of stuff and jim
Starlin really took really took Adam
warlock and turn him into more of a
cosmic character where he was dealing
with like cosmic events and different
things like that but stardom was also
the one responsible for creating a kind
of rapport between Thanos and Adam
warlock and that's why whenever you guys
look his character up you see this sort
of camaraderie or at least is this sort
of respect that goes on between himself
and Thanos even if they're not the best
of friends that was all predicated on
the work that jim Starlin did but I
would say more important than him was a
guy named Roy Thomas so Roy Thomas was
this writer who had his hands on
everything and model back in the day
probably the single most important
writer in Marvel Comics has had a Stan
Lee like he had a huge hand like almost
all the modern depictions of characters
at UC and Marvel Comics is all based on
the work that we Thomas did like Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby created those
characters but Roy Thomas kind of
evolved them into the characters that
they are now but the overall gist here
is that you know between the time that
you had jim Starlin taking over adam
warlock and when adam warlock fought
Thor you had the events of the High
Evolutionary and the High Evolutionary
is a guy named Herbert Windham right and
this is a guy who's basically obsessed
with mutate I'm not really with mutation
but with evolution so he's very akin to
like mr. sinister the difference is that
mr. sinister is obsessed with the
genealogy of of Jean Grey and Cyclops
writing you know like if they ever had
had a child it would be like this
obscene insanely powerful child that was
really kind of where his obsession kind
of culminated I mean he was obsessed
with like the mutant gene but outside of
that it was really more like Jean Grey
and Cyclops
with the High Evolutionary it was like
evolving humanity right and so Herbert
Wyndham was like this genius scientist
who was in Britain all kind of sub I
think I went to Oxford or something like
that anyway he was more or less
didn't for his his radical ideas on
evolution and ended up like evolving
himself he's crazy powerful in terms of
the powers that he possesses heating
like Row two huge sizes and really like
like all kinds of different things he
can give himself powers by like hyper
evolving himself but he's best known for
taking like like animals you know like
like you know cows and things like that
and actually like you know evolving them
for example um when when magneto during
the story of magneto I in his origin
when he and his wife had escaped from
the concentration camps during World War
two and then eventually settled down
when everything went south with them and
and like people realized my mito have
powers they burned his house down which
killed his daughter and his wife took
off she was pregnant with Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver she came across the the
wundagore mountains which is where the
High Evolutionary resides and then she
basically ran into his his sentient
bovine I care for what her name was it
wasn't Magda because that was the name
of of Magneto's like I care what her
name was but basically like she handed
the children over to to this bovine who
hand him over to the High Evolutionary
and then you know Magneto's wife took
off into the woods and then basically
died you know from from exposure to the
elements but uh but he's really big on
that like evolving things like hyper
evolving things it's kind of like his
big claim to fame but during the stories
of Roy Thomas what had happened was the
High Evolutionary he basically like
planted life on this place called
counter-earth now it always gets a
little murky to me I know that Franklin
Richards created a counter-earth maybe
he recreated I think I think High
Evolutionary was the first one that
created which is basically an earth that
orbited opposite of the moon so he
basically had like two earths orbiting
over there now it was common books I
mean that would screw up tides on both
planets so but you would probably lead
to the destruction of both worlds to be
honest but whatever comic book logic
just go with it but I think I think
Michael Richards ended up recreating it
later on but regardless of the
circumstance there was basically this
like alternate earth and what this did
is it howls like all these different
forms of life that the High Evolutionary
had created including one named man
beast and man beast was sort of a Roy
Thomas stand-in for like Satan more or
less and so what ended up happening is
Adam warlock who was eventually like
discovered woken up that kind of stuff
by it by the High Evolutionary who said
like you have to go to counter earth and
fight man-beast and in order to prepare
him and give him what he needed the
tools he needed to win he gave him the
soul stone now we don't know where where
the High Evolutionary got the soul stone
before he gave it to Adam warlock we
just know he had it and so he gave it to
Adam Adam went over to counter-earth
ended up finding man beast
lost the first time and then he was
crucified and then he won the second
time and then basically man beast was
was essentially defeated but you know
you take that concept and he's thrown
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
you run into a couple hairy areas right
there right yeah I mean one like the
Infinity stones already exists we
already know that from the events of
infinity war and an Avengers endgame and
even all the movies that took place
before that and none of them were in the
possession of High Evolutionary it's not
the we're aware of it was entirely
possible they're like they dispersed and
they're there you know like they they
really aren't indestructible they're
fundamental forces of the universe and
so so long as the universe exists the
Infinity stones will always like come
back in some form or fashion they'll
like be recreated even if they're
destroyed but regardless of the
circumstance there's no reason to
believe the High Evolutionary would have
this little stone if the High
Evolutionary does not have the soul
stone then that kind of throws out the
whole basis behind which he would be
involved with Adam warlock and again it
just seems like it'd be too much to fold
in because what you're talking about is
a movie where the guardians of the
galaxy encounter Adam warlock for the
first time Adam warlock and then
presumably face off against each other
since Adam warlock who basically the I
would be brand new it would be like if
you took a you know just kind of clone
to human and then woke them up all the
confused and scared about the world
around them and then they just kind of
react accordingly um and then in turn
somewhere in the mix you throw in the
High Evolutionary I don't really know
how that works the only way you could
really throw the High Evolutionary into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is if you
use it as a way to throw in mutants
right now I know I'm always talking
about like the x-men honestly I just
want to see the x-men in the MCU I don't
care how they do it but what you could
basically say is you could say that like
the High Evolutionary was the one who
basically like
evolved the genes of like Scarlet Witch
and Quicksilver and they're they're
basically like mutants it's just they
never knew right they they always
thought they were just like humans who
somehow got powers presumably from the
tesseract but what you can say is the
like the High Evolutionary like neo
modify their jeans or something like
that so that when they were exposed to
some extreme level of power some exotic
level of power it activated those jeans
and basically they're the first step in
the experiment right and so like once
the High Evolutionary knows it works he
synthesizes whatever it is and spreads
it across the world and that's where
mutants come from there's there's a lot
of different ways that they could do
that but but to take a character like
him and throw him into the the MCU is
kind of quirky because like the high
evolutionary's fought Galactus and like
held his own so he's by no means a weak
character right like the evolutionary
war like he's he's by no means a weak
character like he's pretty intense and
he's pretty tough I mean like he would I
mean if I'm being honest even Thanos
like in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the version of them that didn't have the
Infinity Gauntlet like High Evolutionary
probably could have beat the hell out of
him well you probably could have just
like could have crushed him quite
readily and if you couldn't hear just
like hyper evolve himself and then give
him whatever powers he needed enhanced
strength or speed or whatever in order
to defeat downs but like he could topple
him you know I mean you take High
Evolutionary from the comics you pit him
against Thanos from the MCU and like
High Evolutionary would blend now along
us because the characters that we see in
a Marvel Cinematic Universe are usually
weaker than the versions that we see in
the comics for good reason because
you're talking about a more tangible
realistic version of those characters
but the fact remains that that throwaway
the High Evolutionary into the MCU it is
a cool idea but I feel like guardians of
the galaxy 3 would just be too much it
would be too soon and and it would just
be kind of throwing a ton of stuff in
there right it would be like if you had
a Captain America the First Avenger and
like I'm sorry I woody was like half the
America the First Avenger um Captain
America - the Winter Soldier and you had
like Bucky Barnes and like with that
whole confer with Bucky Barnes like the
Red Skull comes back like it would be
like okay I mean he'd be cool but like
there's a lot of stuff going on to that
movie anyway just be too much and so
again like it would be it would work but
just kind of trying too hard so my
thought is if they even throw in the
High Evolutionary I would save him for a
different movie obviously I would make
him the main villain of like in Avengers
story because he easily could be you
make him like the main villain facing
off against the Avengers oh it would
work so easily because he's just so
powerful and so capable
Bottle know let me know what you guys
think down in the in the comments
section I'm really curious what you're
all thought is again as far as I'm aware
it's just a rumor that's kind of
circulating out there but I thought we
could address it you know and have this
about it you know got into the galaxy
and High Evolutionary the MCU explained
or something like that but uh that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come
this explain it make sure you guys with
the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoy this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later
[Music]
[Music]